so I called him a piece of paper white
balance today I want to talk about the
three empires that are covered in this
chapter even though what the Persians
had was certainly not an empire we call
it an empire out of courtesy they simply
have the country
those three empires are all Muslim in
the sense that the populations are
primarily let's say the ruling elements
of the populations are Muslims even
though the Indian and the Ottoman state
are multi-ethnic and multi-religious but
because of the sort of image that Islam
has in world history we sort of stress
the idea that these are the the media
the late medieval or the early modern
Muslim empires the period that we're
talking about though say 1500 down to
1700 or so is the heyday of the European
notion of the Divine Right of Kings and
it is a period of a greatly diminished
notion of the divine right of Muslim
rulers Europe is more intensely
religious during this period than the
Islamic world in terms of the way in
which the the structures of their States
are conceived we don't tend to recognize
this because since Europe moves in a
direction of secularism after the French
Revolution we tend to see the religious
phase of Europe as something that is
about to pass away and we by contrast
tend to exaggerate the religious
dimension of the Muslim States when I
say that the Muslim states were less
religious I'm talking about what I see
although perhaps no one else yet sees as
a profound change in the character of
Islamic political structure
that begins before this time
shortly before and comes to a to a
fruition in this period the period of
transition is from let us say somewhere
around eleven seventy five down to old
1300 or so and it's it coincides with
and do some degree is directly involved
with the disappearance of the Caliphate
in Islam a political institution called
the Caliphate is said to have come into
being the day after the death of the
Prophet Mohammed when a friend of his
was claimed by the community mourning
the loss of its profit as the Khalifa as
the Caliph a word that means successor
initially it may have meant successor to
God eventually it came to be thought of
as a successor to the Messenger of God
doesn't make a whole lot of difference
and in fact the story we have about how
the Caliphate originated may have been
an invention of later chroniclers we
don't have to to think about this but I
think the one thing that's fairly clear
is that the the Caliphate was focused on
defending and extending the realm of
Islam on the one hand
and on the other hand manifesting the
the the Muslim character of the state
there were different theories as to what
warranted someone claiming the title of
Calif and essentially you have three
theories one theory maintained
that's the Calif or a word that is
sometimes synonymous the Imam that the
Calif or Imam should be a member of the
family of Mohammed descended from his
first cousin Ali the reason it should be
this person was variously explained by
different schools of Muslim thinkers
some people said that it was a matter of
sort of dynastic legitimacy that
Muhammad should be succeeded by this
cousin who was also the father of
Muhammad's grandchildren because he
married Muhammad's daughter
his name was Fatima some people said
that it isn't a matter of blood descent
of this sort but rather a matter of a
divine ordination by which God has
identified the person who should be the
leader of the Muslim community and the
signs of that identification are diverse
depending on your school of thought some
people said this identification took the
form of designating that whichever
member of the family of ali fought for
rule and achieved it was therefore the
imam because
God had helped him achieve Dominion
other people said no the the Imam is to
be determined by the explicit
designation of the current Imam he picks
one of his sons to succeed him show you
different ideas but all of the ideas
that look upon a member of the family of
Ali as by some definition of divine
right being the mmm we call all of those
Shiite and it is in fact the defining
character of shiism Shiites are people
who believe that the leadership of the
Muslim community is divinely ordained to
be in the family of Ali
the other end of the spectrum and to say
instead of having divine designation the
other in the end of the spectrum
was the idea that some some people see a
sort of prototype mccr attic that the
most pious person of the community
should be the Imam and it was sort of a
purist sort of concept and these people
are called the Harwich Heights so you
have shiism Harwich ism and then the
third form is sun desam the Shiites
today are dominant in Iran they're the
majority population in Iraq Bahrain
possibly in Lebanon they are a very
substantial minority in Afghanistan and
Pakistan and among the Muslim community
in India they are a very substantial
group the Harwich Heights today have
virtually disappeared they continue in
their contemporary form only in the
Sultanate of Oman so all the rest of the
Muslims are some nice I put it this way
because the word suddeniy doesn't really
have a very explicit definition in the
early centuries of Islam it is kind of a
residual category those people who are
not Harwich i'ts those people are not
Shiites are so facto sun knees and what
defined being a Sunday was became sort
of elusive the word comes from Sunnah
which means tradition and it means
specifically the tradition of the
community other tradition of the Prophet
there's another word for tradition that
means specifically the words and deeds
of the Prophet Muhammad has handed down
and collected in certain canonical works
almost of the same importance as the
Quran that word for tradition is hadith
so I want clearly to distinguish between
the word son know which is a the
behavior of a community and that we
translate tradition and the the word
heavy hadith which means a specific
prophetic tradition books on Sunnah
will cover all sorts of things from
theology down to day-to-day practice are
we calling it reading one translation
into English a few years ago that had
section where it said the son of hair is
that a man must shave his upper lip he
must shave his head he must shave his
pubic hair and must shave the hair on
the palms of his hands and I thought I I
don't have any hair on the palms of my
hands and in fact if I did I think it
would be demonic and I would end up on
the sci-fi channel in some fashion so I
asked the translator whether possibly
what it really meant was shaved the hair
and the armpits and she said well but
the word was the palm of the hand and I
thought it was worth at least a footnote
but you know the notion of Sunnah goes
all the way from this sort of thing like
how do you drink water how do you
urinate how do you
maintain the palms of your hands goes
all the way from that two questions of
how the Calif is chosen and in the
Sydney notion the Calif is conceptually
an elective office but the notion of
election pretty much subsided after the
first two or three Kahless and was
supplanted by a two-step process of
nomination and oath of allegiance so
that typically the current Calif would
designate his successor and then there
would be an oath of allegiance by the
population called abaya and that oath of
allegiance would confirm the the Calif
in in power in the early days in Mecca
Medina the oath of allegiance was taken
collectively by the entire population
and we have a great deal written about
certain people who would raise
objections to the elevation of someone
to the Caliphate by refusing to take the
aya but the Biot refusing to swear the
oath of allegiance but by the the late
700s did it become customary for the for
the chief judge or some other religious
dignitary to take the oath of allegiance
on behalf of the population
so essentially you had a Calif who had
come to power probably because his
father designated him and then he would
designate a son and this and when the
Calif died the son would be confirmed in
power by the Biot sworn by the chief
judge possibly with some other
dignitaries on behalf of the population
in other words something that was
conceptually elective
and dependent upon the consent of the
governed in some respects had
deteriorated into simply dynastic
dynastic succession nevertheless if you
were the Calif you were entitled to
certain regalia certain signs of rule
that then get mentioned in history books
as indicators of who is ruling for
example once you are the Calif you get
to put your name on the coinage and
frequently this is how we know who is
ruling at a certain point you look at
the coins from from that mint and you
find out whose name is on the coinage it
also means that during the the sermon
that takes place during the noon prayer
on Friday when there are prayers for the
ruler the Calif will be mentioned by
name and these two items of regalia were
important public indicators of who the
Caliph was you would think people would
know the Calif is but you know it's good
to remind people may his study of the
London poor in the early 19th century
revealed that a very substantial
percentage of the poor people of London
did not who'd know who the king was some
of them didn't know they had a king so
you can't assume that everybody knows
who the Caliph is you also got to have
the Caleb's name written on ceremonial
garments that were handed out to
appointees to office to show that they
were under the patronage of that
particular ruler so you have quarrels
among Harwich i'ts Shiites and Sunnis
about who should be the Caliph or who
should be the mmm different theories
different struggles and when someone
seizes power
as would happen from place to place and
time to time they would frequently try
to legitimize their power by getting a
letter or a proclamation from the Calif
who would say you are now my legitimate
appointee so you the word Sultan which
is his at this time of the time of this
chapter for the Ottoman ruler is a word
meaning power and it originally meant
the temporal worldly power of the Calif
and what happens is that the notion of
the worldly power of the Calif becomes
separated from the from the religious
authority of the Caliph so you have a
sultan who says I am acting on behalf of
the Caliph but in order to do that he
had to have the the authorization of the
Caliph so you might have someone who
conquers a province on some frontier of
Islam and he would write a letter to the
Caliph say I have conquered say a
Kashmir and I would like to be
recognized by how my conquest recognised
by you and the Caliph would write back
and say I received your letter I hereby
recognize you as the governor of Kashmir
on my behalf I confer upon you the title
of such-and-such
and I am sending you a horse as a gift
and a robe of honour that will have my
name on it on condition that you mint
coinage with my name on it and that of
the Friday prayers when prayers are
blessings are summoned upon the rulers
your name is mentioned after my name so
it's a very formal kind of thing but it
was terribly important because it was
the essence of what made a legitimate
Muslim ruler rather than simply a
warlord now there were plenty of
warlords around if we tend not to hear
much about them in the Chronicles
because
they don't rise to the level of gaining
this sort of authorization mode if you
read sort of fine-grained study as you
find that there are lots of people who
are trying to seize power in a
particular area but the notion of having
the authority of the Calif as the
touchstone was always there and of
course conditioned upon the definition
of what constituted a Calif but it was a
CI definition or a fair Ajay definition
or a Sunni definition and sometimes you
could have more than one Calif being
defined in different ways after 969 for
202 202 years you had a Calif in Cairo
who is a Shiite and a Calif in Baghdad
who was a Sunday so for that earlier
period those earlier centuries of Islam
you can talk about the the underlying
political theory is the theory of
Caliphate or mm8
and people struggle for this sort of
credential now that disappears in large
part after the year 1200 so that during
this period of the Ottoman Safavid and
mogul empires while the rulers are
Muslims and they are powerful and they
use a title like Sultan or Shah Henshaw
King of Kings and Persian their
relationship to the ultimate
legitimating authority of Islam has
become quite different
to me this change is best indicated by
an event that shows up in every world
history textbook but I think has not
been sufficiently identified in its
importance and this event took place in
1187 and it was the reconquest of
jerusalem by the muslim general Saladin
or salahuddin the Crusaders had captured
Jerusalem during the First Crusade that
began in 1098 and they held Jerusalem
for almost 100 years
and then Saladin led the the Muslim
armies of Egypt and Syria against the
Crusaders and reconquered the city
Saladin was Kurdish which in normal
definitions of the caliphate now to say
in the Shiite and the Sydney definition
was a Caliphate disqualified him for
being Calif though among the Hara G's if
they have still been around and they
were very few left by that time he could
have been the Calif okay Hara G's always
said that the best of the community is
the Imam of the community even if he is
a black slave but in this case the
Sunnis had traditions that maintain that
the Calif must be an Arab and many of
them specified must be an Arab from the
same tribe as Muhammad the tribe of
Quraish among the Shiites they said that
the Calif or the Imam must be a
descendant of Ali Muhammad's son-in-law
and first cousin which of course also
would make him a member of that tribe so
here you have a man like
saladin occurred in a period when most
of the powerful people from Afghanistan
across to Egypt most of the the generals
who really held power were not Arabs
they were either Kurds or Turks more
Turks and Kurds sometimes they were
Armenians there was some important
Armenian converts to Islam who played
significant roles but in the case of
Saladin he has occurred he sends a
letter to the Caliph in Baghdad after
taking Jerusalem saying my valiant
troops have retaken the holy city of
Jerusalem and the Caliph writes back and
said actually those are the valiant
troops of the Caliph who have retaken
Jerusalem and Saladin writes back and
says no they're my troops they retaken
Jerusalem because the Calif really
hadn't lifted a finger against the
Crusaders over the preceding period of
close to a century because the Calif
didn't have any power to speak of he
just had legitimating authority later
that year at the end of the year Saladin
picked one of his top military
commanders to lead the pilgrimage to
Mecca and a caravan went to Mecca as it
would do every year under the command of
this individual and of course at the
same time the caravan set out from
Baghdad with an Emir appointed by the
Caliph to lead the caravan on the
pilgrimage to Mecca so the two caravans
plus caravans from other places Yemen
and so on arrived and they are camped
out in one of the
pilgrimage sites located outside the
Mecca and on the day when they are
supposed to go into Mecca the head of
the Syrian Caravan says okay play the
drums let's get going we're going into
Mecca now and the head of the iraqi
caravan said actually i go first and you
don't come with your caravan until my
caravan has gone first and the syrian
says there is actually no authority that
says that you go first and i'm ready to
go
so play the drums so a battle broke out
people were killed
you had professional soldiers plus the
various pilgrims themselves from Iraq
and Syria fighting it out and in the
process of the battle the Syrian Emir is
mortally wounded so they take him to the
tent of the Iraqi Emir the Iraqi Emir
says you know this really wasn't the
time and place for us to get into this
dispute so let's just kind of forget
about it but then the Syria the mayor
died it is fairly clear to me this
episode I've never seen a translation of
and it shows up in in a major Chronicle
but nobody's ever paid much attention to
it but seems to me that this epitomizes
what is happening at this point which is
that Saladin is claiming greater
authority than the Calif and yet he has
no claim to being the Imam of the
community he's not an Arab he is not the
holder of any position granted by the
Caliph
but he has taken the holy city of
Jerusalem a few years later Cameron the
exact day that's around 1204 something
like that an inscription has been found
now to say the date of the inscription
dates to a few years after this event
and in the inscription Saladin is
identified as on the one hand the master
of the harbour Sharif that is say the
Muslim shrine in Jerusalem and on the
other hand he's identified as hot amel
hotter mine which means the servitor of
the two holy places meaning Mecca and
Medina so the inscription is basically
saying that Saladin now controls the
three holy cities of Islam whether they
had ever been brought together as a
threesome before this I don't know but
they clearly show up as a threesome now
that Saladin had recaptured Jerusalem
and he was claiming authority over Mecca
and Medina and he was using a title
servitor of the two holy places
hoddan which means servant and El
harmine
which means the is a duel that's of the
two harems the two sacred places
so now Saladin not only is claiming this
this Authority or rather I should say he
is claiming a certain functional
priority the Calif may have used the
term audible Hara mine before this I
have not seen it but I was reported to
me by someone that there is a text in
which the Calif uses it but this is the
first time it shows up as sort of a
free-standing title and it's an
interesting title first because it it is
separate from the issue of divine
legitimation it is simply saying de
facto I hold the power to be the
authority over the holy cities of Islam
but secondly and perhaps more
importantly this title of Hanuman hotter
line persists from that time from
roughly 1200 down to the present day as
a significant functional title for
whoever controls Mecca Medina
it is a shift from authority based upon
divine little legitimation weather of a
hereditary sort or of an elective sort
to an authority based upon functioning
in a certain role with respect to the
Muslim community but without a divine
appointment to do so in 1258 the last
Calif in Baghdad is killed by the
Mongols there are a couple of people
over the following year or so who claim
the title of caliph because the position
is now empty one ruler in Tunisia one in
Yemen but the fact of the matter is
there there is no that there's no real
mechanism for deciding after that who
will be the who will be the Caliph then
Turkish generals who are in power in
Egypt who have seized power in Egypt
from the descendants of Saladin they
find a relative of the last Calif they
put him on a throne in Cairo and they
call him the Caliph and nobody pays any
attention to him
so you have what sometimes called the
shadow Caliphate that lasts until the
Ottoman conquest of 1517 the Turkish
generals who are ruling in Cairo in
other words create a legitimizing
Authority that is totally under their
control but they also continue to retain
a title that is not given to the Caliph
but is reserved to themselves which is
autumn ohan or mine the servitor to holy
places because starting with Saladin
and his descendants and continuing under
the Turkish military rulers in Egypt and
Syria the idea that you serve Islam and
legitimize your rule by by guaranteeing
the function of Islam in particular in
the form of the pilgrimage to Mecca
Medina and you defend the Muslim
community against enemies whether those
enemies are Crusaders who were still
around in 1250 when our 1260 when the
Calif has set up in Cairo or whether you
are defending the Muslim community
against the pagan Mongols or the
non-muslim Mongols who have invaded and
killed the Caliph in Baghdad
you know the dual function of the ruler
which is to protect the Muslim community
and to facilitate its its carrying out
of the ritual functions of Islam and in
this period in the 1,400 1,300 1400s
1500s you have a kind of acceleration of
a strong ritualization of Islam as a
day-to-day practical religion but the
issue over who is the legitimate ruler
that would say in divine turns the
question over whom God wishes to have in
charge of community that becomes largely
moot the Arabs are pretty much done you
don't have Arabs ruling in except in
rather remote areas particularly in
southern Arabia you have Turks you have
Kurds you have Iranians none of whom are
have the bloodlines that would warrant
their being considered in mammals or
caliphs so to a large degree the later
period of Islam
is experienced within a political theory
that is quite different from the
medieval one and one in which the ruler
is functioning as a protector of Islam
or a guardian of Islam and a facilitator
or guarantor of the practice of Islam
but he is not a Muslim ruler in some
sort of divinely ordained sense now
after 1500 this becomes challenged in
Iran and Iran under the Safavids has a
government in which the ruler does claim
to have divine ordination the Safavid
family makes a claim to represent God's
will or to be ruling on behalf of the
person whom God will ultimately send to
restore perfect rule on the face of the
earth but in sunny areas that's a Shiite
theory in sunny areas you don't have
divine authority dragged into two
debates
scholars may still do it but in
practical terms you have a much more
let's say a more mundane type of
justification for rule if you were doing
this and comparative European terms you
might look at say the shift from the
Merovingian kings of the Franks who are
divinely ordained as the rulers of this
community of Germans after the fall of
the Roman Empire being replaced by
Charlemagne who starts out basically as
their chief chief Butler who you know
Rises power and his family the
Carolingians have no divine legitimation
in the way that their predecessors the
Merovingians
Stift so we're moving away from religion
as a central defining element of rule at
least religion in the divine right sense
so this is where Europe is moving in
another direction
you know the feudal Europe of many many
different Dukes and counts and so forth
did not rely that much upon divine
ordination it was assumed that you had a
Christian community and that ultimately
Christians owed allegiance to the Pope
but the idea that a ruler was
specifically designated by God as king
by right
this is something that's certain that
arises later in European history that
would say after forty hundred fifteen
hundred whereas it is exactly what is
diminishing in the Muslim world in order
to back this up
the Muslims who controlled the holy
places a put increasing emphasis upon
the pilgrimage anyone who the study I
think about Islam will know that there
are five pillars of Islam
you know prayer alms fasting declaration
of gods know oneness and Muhammad's role
as his messenger and the performance of
the pilgrimage but prior to 1200
performance of the pilgrimage was a
comparatively minor part of the Muslims
religious obligations Oh Muslim was
supposed to perform the pilgrimage once
during a lifetime if he or she was
financially capable but when you look at
the city of Mecca circa 1150 or so it
seems to only have maybe 5,000
year-round residents it has virtually no
water and it doesn't grow any food the
sustenance of the city of Mecca depended
in substantial part on the taxes or the
tolls that were charged from the
pilgrims so it was expensive to make the
pilgrimage what we know of the of the
toll that was charged at the time of
that salad and took over was that it was
seven dinars which is a very very large
sum seven gold coins but they needed the
money to support the holy cities because
there was virtually nothing there by the
way of an infrastructural support salad
and canceled the tolls and took the
supply of of food and water and services
for Mecca Medina took those as
government obligations for the
government of Egypt and Syria and they
remain government obligations to this
day first under Saladin's descendants
then under the Turkish generals who took
over him from his family in 1250 then
under the Ottoman Sultans who took over
from the Turkish generals in 1517 and
now under the the Saudi royal family
which seized power in the 1920s and this
is a very very serious serious thing
because it's not only providing for the
pilgrims but it also is a way of
demonstrating to pilgrims what there is
at the center of Islam in other words
Islam has this concept called the Ummah
the Ummah is the Muslim community at any
point in time at a worldwide entity all
Muslims are part of the Ummah they may
have divisions on different grounds
different sects different theories but
they're all one let's say the closest
term you would get on the Christian side
would be christened them but Christendom
tends to imply mil itical domination
it's where where Christianity is
dominant but the OMA has no implication
of of anything other than simply
brothers and sisters within Islam
this idea which is seemingly present in
the lifetime of Muhammad and seems to be
part of documents that that go back to
the preaching of Muhammad this concept
is still vital among Muslims today and
you you compare Islam with other
religions and you don't really find that
is there a world Christian community
well not exactly in the way that they
have or is there a world Buddhist
community or a world Hindu community
note the divisions and all these other
religions are significant enough that
people don't normally refer to everybody
is belonging to the same community but
in Islam they do claim they're part of
the same community the notion of the
Imam or the caliph was for the first
five hundred years or so the touchstone
of this notion of Ummah all Muslims who
were educated knew that there was
someone somewhere who was the leader of
the Muslim community and who would be no
you you there's a place you could go to
where you could find him whether it was
originally in Medina in Arabia or then
in Damascus or in Baghdad there was
someone who was the head of the Ummah
and he could be called the kala for the
Imam when the last Calif is killed in
1258 by the Mongols and the Calif who is
cranked up in Cairo gains no traction as
a focus of political loyalty and in fact
when the ottomans take over in 1517 they
simply dispense with that shadow calif
in cairo they have no need for him when
the Caliphate disappears
in my judgment what happens is that the
pilgrimage becomes the center of the OMA
it's the place where Muslims come
together it's the place where they learn
about one another where the exchanged
views where they see people of many
different colors and languages that come
from all parts the Muslim world it is
the the eloquent physical manifestation
of Islam as a worldwide community so
it's very important important in this
respect that the pilgrimage becomes
vastly more important after the end of
the caliphate than it was during the
caliphate and by more important I mean
more people go in the pilgrimage which
means that Mecca Medina not only have to
be larger but they have to be able to
support more people in the pilgrimage
season which means they need more
supplies which means that whoever is
supplying these desolate desert cities
has to be taking the responsibility to
be the Hatem the Guardian the servitor
of the holy places so what we find is
that in the in the 12 hundreds in
particular I'm 1,300 you start to get
schools being built in Mecca you never
had any before 1200 these schools meddra
seized by Islamic colleges teach people
about Islam and when you look at the
life stories of Muslims from other parts
of the world they go from Indonesia or
from India or from Morocco or from
Senegal to Mecca where they learn about
Islam they already are Muslims they
already know their local custom but they
go to the mattresses in Mecca and Medina
and this is where they learn more
and they stay for several years in
earlier times you could not really
overstate the pilgrimage because there's
no food and water you had to go home on
the pill when the rites were over their
lights only last a few days but now you
had people who were so journeying there
for for several years not only did they
go to school but they would join Sufi
Brotherhood's and the Sufi Brotherhood's
had residences in Mecca Medina we know
there are about thirty mattresses and a
similar number of Sufi convents where
you could where you could stay when you
look at the patronage of these
institutions
none of the patronage comes from from
Iraq the old kala full center it comes
from Yemen it comes from India
it comes from Egypt from Syria and from
local wealthy people and wealthy people
begin to think it would be a holy thing
to facilitate the pilgrimage so they
sponsor public works and means for
people to soldier in the holy places
this also leads to a strategic alignment
of Egypt Syria and Yemen because these
control the important avenues to Mecca
and Medina prior to 1100 Yemen really
was an outlying area that nobody cared
about very much it was linked with Egypt
but that was under a Shiite dynasty but
now Egypt Syria and Yemen become more
closely linked and then Sudan becomes an
important area when the conquest of
Islam originally occurred a truce had
been reached on the what is now the
border between
Egypt and Sudan the conquest stopped
there was a treaty and the Christians of
Sudan were not attacked by the Muslim
armies in Egypt until now when you start
to have Sudan becoming strategically
important because it is so close to
Arabia across the Red Sea from the holy
cities so there's a a great change in
the weight of this part Middle East from
what it had been say in nine hundred or
ten hundred nine hundred ten hundred
almost all of the weight of political
and religious and cultural influence in
the Islamic Middle East was in Iraq and
Iran now Iraq and Iran are sort of cut
off and the weight shifts to Egypt Syria
Yemen and to a lesser degree Sudan one
of the marks of this new valuation of
the pilgrimage is that people begin to
to add to their personal names the title
Hajji which means someone who has made
the pilgrimage
you can also be al-hajj
people who made the pilgrimage before
1200 may have you as the title Hajji but
if they did I have not found it even
though I have specialized in reading
Muslim biographical dictionaries and
I've gone through literally tens of
thousands of capsule biographies of
Muslim scholars many of whom it will say
you know he made a pilgrimage in such
such a year but you never see the title
Hajji after 1300 you have Hajis popping
up all over the place but particularly
in outlying areas like Indonesia in the
China West Africa and when you look into
the Anthropology of the pilgrimage in
these areas you often find a profound
change in status that a person acquires
after they return from the pilgrimage
they can wear different clothes because
they are Haji they can decorate their
house like their front door in a
different fashion because they are Haji
they can be or claim to be authorities
on Islam because they are Haji and
indeed by the time you get to the 19th
century if you aren't Haji you probably
don't count for a whole lot
interestingly while the mahadji's for
the Muslims are those who go to Mecca
Medina for the pilgrimage at the end of
every year Christians pick up the
practice and they start to call people
who make a pilgrimage to Jerusalem Haji
so you have Greeks who will be Haji
but Dalton because they went to Mecca
Medina because they went to Jerusalem
and not with the Muslims but more with
the Christians you have this becoming
part of surnames so you have Greeks who
are named
hadji often a CEO or Haji Giorgio or
Haji Constantino or something like that
and it's not just the Greeks I'm told
that this extends into the Balkans and
what it points to is not simply that
Mecca Medina become more important but
that for this part of the world
pilgrimage takes on a much more profound
meaning that I've had earlier now
normally when you lecture on pilgrimage
in world history to talk about
pilgrimage leading up to the Crusades
that Christians made a pilgrimage to
Jerusalem they found Jerusalem was held
by the Saracens they said next year in
Jerusalem let's kill the Saracens and
then you have the Crusades but this is a
later period of pilgrimage that doesn't
have a parallel with the pilgrimages of
medieval Christianity so in Christianity
going to Rome going to constantinople
going to jerusalem going to Santiago de
Compostela in Spain this is what need
evil Christians did when they made a
pilgrimage but now it is more than the
Muslim the Middle Eastern form of
pilgrimage that becomes that becomes the
dominant one and the rulers gain
credibility by claiming that they are
the the servitors of the holy pilgrimage
cities in Cairo in I think in the 12 60s
back on frames of camera in Cairo I
believe in the 12 60s there is a new
custom that arises which is that when
the pilgrimage starts every year it will
be led by a shrine an empty room built
on top of a camel and the exterior of
this shrine will be elaborately
decorated with cloth hangings and googas
and so forth and the the camel with the
empty room on top will lead the
pilgrimage to Mecca Medina this practice
is in Cairo as I say I believe in the
1260 s continues down to the 1920s every
year you have the ceremonial camel and
once they started in Syria then other
people want to send their ceremonial
camel then they'll want to compete over
whose camel gets to go into Mecca first
and the governor Rebecca usually knowing
where he's getting his grain and his
water from always gives precedence to
the Egyptians but the ceremonial camel
nobody knows the origin of the practice
but the ceremonial camel is before the
caravan starts out he's led around to
all of the to the palaces of all the
major military commanders in Cairo to
sort of receive blessings and so forth
and so on so it it becomes the physical
symbol of the political authority that
is sending out the the caravan it
doesn't go to the Caliph to get
authorization that goes to the major the
major generals
some people have likened this ceremony
of camel to a practice that was observed
the 19th century that certain Arab
tribes when they would travel or go to
war would carry a camel with an empty
room on his back a closed camel saddle
and they would liken that to the Ark of
the Covenant that was carried around by
the ancient Israelites that the lead
there was a sacredness to this to this
space that was moving with the with the
nomads or with in the nomads or in this
case with the caravan all right
the Ottoman Empire had a plausible claim
to being the leading state in the Muslim
world during this period because they
controlled Mecca Medina and at least in
the early 1500s they worked to ensure
that the Europeans would not be able to
interfere with the pilgrimage by moving
ships up into the Red Sea so the defense
of the Red Sea and the and the Gulf of
Oman the southern approaches to the to
Mecca Medina became at least for a while
a very important part of about even the
Ottoman political world there is no
indication that the Ottomans cared a fig
for any of this prior to 1517 when they
take over from the generals in in Cairo
so basically they conquer the the
military regime in Cairo at that time
and they immediately take on the same
geopolitical strategic
aimes that the death of Turkish generals
have had before the Ottomans came they
are essentially expanding their mandate
and clearly deriving of legitimacy from
their new role because the Ottomans take
over this title animal heart mine
there's a scholarly debate over though
they also take over the title Khalifa
and call themselves Calif and there's
some evidence that they do but you can
probably find fifty or hundred citations
of them being called Sodom Ohio mine
through every occasional citation of the
moon called Felipa and the notion of the
Ottoman ruler as a caliph does not gain
any real potency until the late
nineteenth century which I'll talk about
in a later lecture so it's really this
role of protecting Islam that is that
becomes the benchmark of what a Muslim
ruler is in this later period I had not
originally thought to lecture on this
today but I've been thinking about it a
lot a lot lately because I think that it
is very substantially at the root of the
Arab Spring to jump ahead to a later
chapter of the book one for example not
yet written
a year ago there were eight Arab
monarchies there were seven military
officers States and there were two
anomalous Arab States one in Iraq under
American occupation and the other in
Lebanon with its own particular you know
multi-ethnic multi
formation of those Arab states five of
them have now either lost their rulers
or are on the verge of doing so I have
to say the ruler of Egypt the ruler of
Tunisia the ruler of Libya are out of
power the ruler of Yemen is out of power
but doesn't seem to know it yet and the
ruler of Syria is is more up in the air
that's five of the seven officer states
the other two Algeria and Sudan are
either immersed in or only recently
exiting tremendous civil wars that have
exhausted their populace in the case of
Algeria you might say that the Arab
Spring came in 1992 when when you had
popular motions that were put down by
the military regime so none of the
monarchies have fallen and five of the
officer regimes have Eero of either
fallen or are desperately at risk
why that why that difference
I'm also pointing out that the Bahrain
had been experiencing a lot of
demonstrations but Bahrain was
guaranteed by other Arab monarchies
particularly Saudi Arabia but also other
Gulf Sultanate for Emirates you'll
notice that nobody came to the aid of
the officer States no you have a problem
in Tunisia
azita say oh we will send troops to
defend no each the monarchies are in it
together
the officer regimes are in it separately
so what's the difference there are
different ways to look at it one way is
to say that all of the monarchies were
established by imperialist powers or
inclusion with imperialist powers that
in some cases imperialist powers would
literally decide who was going to be the
the Emir Abu Dhabi is a famous example
because the Emir of Abu Dhabi was a
Shake Shack boot who had a small coterie
of great admirers in the West and Shaq
boot was installed by the British and
then they found that once oil was
discovered and they started to export
the oil they would go to Shaq boot and
they'd say well now you need a seaport
he said well actually to export the oil
you need a seaport so you build a
seaport I'm not going to spend my money
on the Seaport so I'd say well you know
when we visit you in the palace we don't
like to eat with our fingers so well you
know bring your own silver I'm in heat
he would not spend any money and he
insisted that his oil royalties be paid
in the currency of Abu Dhabi which was
the Indian rupee coin so he had his bed
was under his body and piles of coin
she had palaces of coins and them he
wouldn't spend any money and he said you
know the oil companies they cannot
export the oil unless they spend money
so why should they spend my money when
they should spend their own night and so
then the British sent some some
strong-armed people and they put him on
a plane and said your brother is now the
Emir of Abu Dhabi and his brother Sheikh
Zayed you know it was a much more
agreeable fellow smiling all the time
like Shaq booty literate but you know he
let the oil companies in the British do
what they wanted so the imperialist set
up the monarchies but the military
regimes were all revolutionary they all
define themselves as Arab nationalists
Vanguard
soldiers against imperialism
you know we drive out the British and
the French and their lackeys and we
fight against Israel this is what we do
we define our are we our credibility as
Arab nationalist leaders by defending
the Muslim community against its enemies
this is exactly what the Turkish rulers
the Mamluks had done back in the 13th
century they define their ruler by
protecting the Muslim community and
fighting against Crusaders and Mongols
now the definition is that they fight
against Crusaders and Jews by definition
I mean that is what is I'm a good Latin
said in his propaganda he said we must
all get together to fight against the
Crusaders and the Jews because they are
killing us off and our governments are
not standing up for us so what happened
was that
these nationalist regimes that had
defined their legitimacy by opponent but
by opposing imperialism whether it was
British or French or Russian or or
Israeli or American they define
themselves by that and then over the
last few years since 1991 and even more
since 9/11 they quit fighting
imperialism they became America's allies
they said you know if America says that
Islamic radicalism is the great danger
we will suppress the Islamic radicals
and we welcome American support America
wants to have predator aircraft that go
and shoot rockets the people in our
territory because they're anti-terrorist
we're anti-terrorist too and if you want
to send us your terrorist suspects we'll
will torture them we'll get the truth
out of them we will do what America
wants and what American wanted was to
demonize radical Islamic activity at
least that portion of it deemed
terrorist or potentially terrorist and
they wanted Iran to become the enemy of
the air world and they wanted the Arab
world to feel friendly about Israel make
peace you know form economic relations
and the regime's by and large these
military officer regimes that had begun
as anti imperialist
nationalists became within the last few
years became America's staunch allies
defining the their function in the world
according to an American vision of of
the role of government but abandoning
their original legitimating claim that
they were defending the Muslim human
community against imperialists and and
Israel to me the Arab Spring was a
consequence of a profound crisis of
legitimacy that did not affect the
kingdoms because the kingdoms had not
were not predicated on the idea that
they would struggle against imperialism
they were all created by imperialism and
they weren't defined by how they're
going to struggle against Israel because
by and large they didn't struggle
against Israel although Jordan did from
time to time so the kingdoms had never
claimed to be anything than what they
were
but these officer regimes had made their
their right to rule dependent upon their
opposition to imperialism into Israel
and their populations whether they had
liked it or not their populations had
come to deeply interiorize that
philosophy so in other words the Arab
populace would say we are the Friends of
the Palestinians we are opposed to
American occupation of Iraq that's
imperialism but the governments were now
on the american side and and they fell
and it was interesting when the
demonstrations began most of the
governments at threat announced islamic
radicals are trying to overthrow us
whereas islamic radicals were very hard
to find in these demonstrations but by
saying that their threat was from
islamic radicals they were essentially
saying what the united states thought
was the underlying situation namely the
America's allies were being threatened
by the evil people who were Islamic
radicals even though it was manifestly
not the case but it was very similar to
what happened during the Cold War when
you would have a dictator who would be
faced with the nationalist uprising and
he would say the Communists are trying
to overthrow my government
the Americans Communists overthrowing
your gut send in the Marines because we
can't let the Communists take over and I
do believe that the Egyptians Tunisians
and others thought that Europe and
America would come to their aid to keep
them in power in the same way that
during the Cold War we came to the aid
of dictators who were threatened by
international communism it didn't happen
ultimately we'll have to find out why it
didn't happen why did the u.s. let its
let these people who claim to be its
allies go but it is the end of a form of
Islamic rule that began in the 13th
century or in the 12th century when you
had protection against outside invaders
and maintenance of of a Islamic regime
nominally an Islamic regime for the
protection of the ritual observances of
Muslim populations that's when this
philosophy came into being and it came
to an end last spring so you can go
through the history of the Ottoman
Empire
and trace this which is actually where I
intended to start today's lecture was to
talk about what what these military
regimes are actually like and how they
worked in terms of monopolizing power
for the military the situation we have
now is that the military regimes have
discarded their rulers but the officers
are still there
and it will take a generation or more to
get the officers out of de facto de
facto power it's something that we tend
not to look at but it's interesting to
think of because the the alternative was
what you saw in Iran in Iran
you had a Shiite regime that claimed to
be ruling on behalf of the Messiah who
would return the mathy and bring perfect
justice and the regimes as they moved
along from the 1500s down to down to the
20th century became less and less
credible as as the forerunners of this
messianic individual so they lost their
religious credibility and they really
and the revolution that came about
shifted the religious credibility onto a
new revolutionary government but the
interesting thing is that in Iran when
the regime fell every military officer
of the rank of colonel or general either
went into exile or was killed or was put
onto retirement this despite the fact
that a war was beginning with Iraq that
would last for eight years the entire
high command of the Iranian military
disappears because every colonel in
general had been personally vetted
by the Shah of Iran so what you had in
Iran was a revolution in which the
entire regime Falls what you've had in
the Arab Spring is a perturbation in a
long history of military officer rule in
which the the top person is discarded
but the structure that put him on top
remains and my guess is that when we
have new constitutions and electoral
laws we'll find that there are
provisions for the military to retain a
lot of privileges for example check out
and see whether Parliament is allowed to
review the military budget whether
Parliament is allowed to to monitor or
audit projects designed to build villas
and provide privileges for military
officers my guess is that you will have
loyal Democrats who cut deals with the
generals when the generals will still be
around 30 years from now whereas in Iran
all the generals are gone but that we
have a new set of generals who are
trying to create the same mess that they
have in the Arab world this was not the
lecture I intended to give today but
it's what I've been consumed with lately
because of other speaking obligations
I've had but also because of the
particular juncture we're at with the
first UN General Assembly meeting after
the Arab Spring and everyone wondering
what what what's happening so I thought
I would tell you what's happening thank
you